well one of my favorites is Josiah
Wedgwood who founded the China company
back in 1759 as I've moved in the middle
age I think about people in this with
this criterion would I shop cook clean
and make dinner for them and invite them
into my home and I would be honored and
just jubilant to have Josiah Wedgwood
come have dinner with me his energy his
curiosity his integrity his deep
knowledge and his constant willingness
to keep on learning you know made him a
real citizen of the world as well as a
brilliant marketer and manufacturer I I
greatly admire Milton Hershey who's
someone much less written about not only
because he helped create a mass market
for chocolate or medicine as my mother
says but because he had a very
interesting very enlightened dream about
using this very successful business he'd
built creating five cent chocolate bars
and creating a social experiment in
which workers and managers shared in in
largely equal parts in the bounty that
capitalism offers that's a very risky
very interesting thing to do and and he
did it to define himself to you know
listen to answer to his own siren songs
but to make a big social contribution
and I think that's interesting and I'm
absolutely mad for estee lauder cosmetic
entrepreneur a woman born in Queens the
very early years of the 20th century
with very few options but a lot of hood
spa a lot of imagination a lot of warmth
and great great ambition and I never met
her I've met many of her family members
but her engagement who her constant
unstoppable wish to make women feel
better about themselves and and her
warmth were just you know enormous
assets to her and and just just again
completely engaging for me like magnets
we finished a case on Oprah Winfrey a
couple of years ago love's a long
interesting journey learning about her
road not so much a personal road
although that's all wrapped up in the
entrepreneurial story but also about her
business and how she built it and what
she's done with it
and how she created an organization that
could carry on her mission and you know
in tandem with her but very much carry
on her mission and she's just an
extraordinary businesswoman we know her
as a woman of great celebrity and you
know of great impact but the business
story is as compelling as a celebrity
story and what she's going to do with
the next few chapters of her of her
journey of her rewards of her company of
her fame is really quite extraordinary
she is she is going to cheetahs changing
education it sub-saharan Africa she's
going to fundamentally change thousands
maybe over time millions of young
women's lives in terms of what they know
where they go how they think who they
teach and help lead and she's going to
do that with with with the tools that
she built by by creating this
phenomenally successful company and it's
not philanthropy as we think of it this
is a woman turning her business toward
overtly social and educational ends and
it's a gutsy and important thing that
she's doing